The Joe Rogan experience. How often are you, uh, doing these free solo climbs?
Uh, you know, I'm working on things like fairly frequently. I dunno,
I was just on this expedition, uh, in the jungle in Guyana,
it was like a national geographic TV show thing and a,
and a free soul of the wall we put up just,
just because the tub of rock we were on,
no one's ever sold at a wall like that before.
So I felt like since we were there as felt almost an obligation to do it just
for like this climbing history, you know, you're like, oh,
if you're there and you have the opportunity, you kind of have to.
Now when you see something like that, do you make a route first with ropes?
Always. Yeah. Yeah. So our, I mean, because we were there, I mean,
it's a whole like complicated, natural graphic TV thing.
So we were there with biologists.
We're like studying these endemic species of the taboos.
There's like this whole interesting natural history component to it. Um,
or sort of biology component, but, um,
but we were just trying to climb this mountain that had never been climbed
before. So the priority is obviously just to get up it,
to like find these species of frogs, to like,
do all the things that are important for the TV show. But then, but then,
because I was there, I was like, oh, you know, on the side,
I can at least do something that I'm proud of in climbing.
That's also pretty cool. Oh, wow. That's pretty cool. Yeah.
So it was like this like pretty, and it wound up being totally insane,
calming like really cool, like this overhanging wall of six, 700 feet high, um,
you know, like dangling, it was kind of the best style of,
of climbing to solar because it felt secure.
Like it's the type of climbing where you feel safe. Like it's very,
very good rock. So anything you hold onto, you know,
is solid and it's not going to break.
And it also lends itself to the sort of striations in the rock where you can
like wedge your hand in and like, feel really secure.
But also it's incredible exposure because it's really steep. Like,
because you're in the jungle, you can only climb stuff.
That's overhanging cause anything that's like less than anything else,
accumulates like water and dirt and winds up with plants all over it.
So like the only stuff that's really climbable is the stuff that is sheltered
from the rains that doesn't have plants on it. So, so it's.
Difficult just.
By nature. So it's difficult because you're hanging.
And so you're like in these crazy positions where you're dangling from your
arms,
but you feel safe doing it because the rocks are so good and the holes are so
good. And you're just like, what a crazy place it's really cool.
But then when you get to the very edge, you have to somehow.
Make your way. And that's a bummer. Yeah. That seems.
Like the most gnarly part of it.
We're actually probably in terms of risk,
it probably was the final 20 or 30 feet of like getting onto the top.
It's all like rotten soil and this rocks and like, you know, yeah.
It wasn't ideal, but.
How do you decide which way to go when you get to something like that?
Just what's the most likely path to.
Yeah. Well, so in that particular case, um,
we had already established the route, you know, like,
because it's this TV thing we'd already climbed. It we'd put ropes up,
but we'd like worked on it. The camera guys had gone up and down.
We'd like camped up on this ledge to look for these frogs. Uh,
we'd like to on this whole experience. So for the free solo,
I already had a pretty good sense of like how I should tackle that part because
you know, we'd already been sort of living out there a bit, but wow. Yeah.
But I'm like, what'd you do in February? You know, that, that was my February.
So these frogs, like the, the idea is to,
is it really an excuse to climb.
Or is it like, do you really,
are you really there for the frogs to check out these weird species?
It's a little bit of both. Yeah. Well, I'm like,
I know this is a long form show. Do you want to like go deep into it? Cause,
cause it's actually really interesting. So, um, right. Long form. So, so,
okay. The trip was, the trip is crazy. I mean, we deserve with the hold up. Uh,
I read freaking eight books while we were there.
Cause it's the jungle and you know, it's the tropics.
So it's dark from six to six every day. It's like 12 hours of dark and uh,
we're in our own little hammock.
So I was just in my Bakun like reading books every day. And so a headlamp. Yeah.
Yeah. But I had my amp because you have nothing else to do.
It's like raining and you're just in your own little like personal cocoon,
just like reading. But um, so I read like natural history of Guyana,
natural history, like, you know, sort of the, the, the geology.
So, um, like have you seen the movie up, like the Pixar Disney movie,
the cute thing with the flying house and the balloons. Yeah. So, you know,
that's all modeled on like where they fly to the big rock things with the
waterfalls. Those are taboos, which are like real things in south America. Um,
that's in Venezuela, Guyana and the Northern part of Brazil.
Or if you've seen the new point break,
they filmed down there on the same rock features. I didn't see that,
but so you're not missing anything it's really bad, but uh,
but a lot of my friends worked on it. So it's like, it's cool.
And it is like an incredible climbing place. Better respect.
Film, Patrick Swayze. I just.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. You didn't, you didn't miss anything.
I actually fell asleep watching it on a plane.
When you fall asleep during an action movie, you're kind of like, come on. Yeah.
But, um, but the climbing at school and, and anyway,
so it was on these things called [inaudible], which are
like these big court Siddiq sandstone walls that stick out of the jungle. And so if you imagine a huge raised area of land that because it's
in the jungle has been massively roaded
by the constant rain over the last 40 million years. So now you wind up with all these like slender sort of towers and
mesas, you know? So like do you know angel falls like know it's
one of the biggest waterfalls in the world here
, like pull up a picture angel falls is, is, uh,
it's like, oh yeah, yeah. That's you know that?
Yes. It's so beautiful. If, if you could.
It looks fake. Yeah. It does look fake. Isn't it crazy?
I'm pretty sure that one is arraignment.
If you look to the left or the one you were just on that,
we climbed this little wall to the left of it. Can.
You go back to that one? Jamie? Cause like if I was a dumb.
So built that totally. So if you could pan that photo to the left though,
obviously you can't. Cause it's not in the frame.
We climb this little mountain to the left.
And so this is a really famous peak cause the summit of it marks the boundary
between Brazil, Venezuela, and Guyana.
It's used as like the marker to separate this three countries.
And so we were climbing this sort of little bastard step brother next to it.
But with, you know, that peak though had never been climbed.
It was like new to science for the different species of frogs and all that kind
of stuff.
Laura and you've stumbled upon that.
You would think that that was like a structure. Yeah.
Like it's so square and flat.
And some of them did like European explorers that first came into the region,
had all kinds of names like the white cathedral and things like that.
Like that tower. Um, they're just a bunch of I'll.
Look at that one click on the one, your cursor's on Jamie that's.
So, oh, actually, so again, so actually you see on the left side of that,
there's like a hint of a little thing in the distance that I'm pretty sure
that's the thing we were climbing to think to the left,
this like just starting to appear out of the clouds. Yeah.
I'm pretty sure it's the peak that we found.
God, it's so beautiful.
Yeah. Yeah. That's crazy. Well, except to be fair, the sun only comes out like,
so we were there in the dry season and it rained like eight hours a day and we
were in the clouds. Nonstop is totally grim and that's a dry season.
So you see these pictures where you're like, it's so beautiful. And you're like,
yeah, for 30 minutes a day, you know,
and the rest of the time you're just in the, get in the water. Yeah.
That's so wild man. Like really, if I stumbled upon that,
I would think someone built that.
Yeah. No, it's totally incredible. I didn't even get to the cool part of it.
Oh it was. So yeah. I asked him about the geology.
Like how does something like that form? It's so strange.
Yeah. So that's the stuff I was reading while we there.
So it's like this huge bed of sandstone, which then gets,
metamorphose like compressed a court site. So I can really,
really hard sandstone and then, you know, the Andes.
So you have gone wanna like one of the mega continents that predates Pangea I
think like, yeah. So like, you know,
if you imagine all the continents on earth were one sort of combined,
so south America in Africa, you know, fit together at the horn. Um,
and so this rock is most similar to rock into parts of Africa
actually. And so in part of what makes the,
the biology there so interesting is that the creatures on the summit of some of
the taboos are more closely related to creatures in Africa than they are to the
ones in the jungle below them. Because,
because the summits have been separated for so long. You see what I'm saying?
Like, because the top of that,
those islands basically they've been separated from the jungle below for so long
that they more closely resemble where they came from in Africa then than the
creatures that live in the rainforest below. It's like this totally incredible.
I mean, it's just, it's just an interesting part of.
Are you aware of the Omax? Do you know what the Omex civilization was? No,
the Omex it's really, it's quite a mystery.
They don't exactly know what they did or you know, what,
what their culture was all about,
but they had these heads that they left behind these sculpted
gigantic stone heads that resemble resemble African.
People. That's not the Easter island stuff or, oh no, that's.
Different. That's different. This is the Omex.
And where were the Omex? South America. Oh yeah. It says Omax.
South America, Mexico central America. And there's a lot of them.
And these images are very, um,
African looking faces and they don't really know what the
history of the war. Huh. And they know they, they,
they think some of them existed in the neighborhood of 6,000 ago.
But you know, when, when you're, when you're looking at stone,
it's hard because they, they just, the carbon date,
the stuff that's around the stone as they unearth it.
But that doesn't really necessarily give them an accurate sense of when it was
constructed. It just gives an accurate sense of how the sediment.
So the stuff in Guyana though, is, um, look on, uh,
on totally different scale. Like the, the stuff that I'm talking about. The,
I think the Dupuis have been eroded away like isolated for 40 million years or
something, which, you know, far predates humans.
And then I think the rock itself is like 1.5 billion years old.
It's like ancient, ancient. It's incredible rock. It's really cool.
But it's so wild the way it formed.
The look. Yeah. It's funny because I mean,
you saw the pushers that looks like islands and you know,
early explorers thought that they must be islands or something,
but it's actually, uh, just the eroded remanence of what was once like a giant,
you know, elevated plateau. Oh yeah, totally.
So this is what the summits look like.
I have a bunch of photos like that on my phone.
It's just like scrappy little iPhone pics of like, here we are on this crazy,
you know, because you're like in the clouds, you're in the mist,
it's like kind of grim and it's raining.
But then the summit is like this totally wild.
So like all those plants are incredibly well adapted to this harsh environment.
And they're, they're really high rates of chronic worry,
like plants that eat things because they're busy, no soil.
One of the books that I read said that described it as a rain desert.
Like you think of a desert normally as having lots of soil, but no water.
And there you have infinite water, but no soil because it's a stone surface.
That's getting rained on so much that it washes all the soil away. Oh wow.
So for any of the vegetation to live there,
they basically all have different strategies where they're rooted straight to
the stone and then they eat, you know, they eat, uh,
bugs and things that, you know,
they eat insects or they eat other plants or they, you know,
they lots of plants that grow on plants and it's just like a whole crazy web of
life. That's like really different than what you expect normally.
Because it's so abundant. Yeah. It's a, it's an unusual form of life,
but it's everywhere. Yeah. Like that's so rich and green, like you'd have.
No, actually I bet if in that photo, if you'd pan the photo, but to the side,
there'd be like big expanses of bare rock because the summits like, yeah,
they're little pastures and things. It's almost like Alpine Meadows.
If you go into the mountains in the Northern hemisphere and there'll be like
high Tundras and things where it's like, yeah, it feels really lush.
But then there's also a lot of exposed rock because when the sun comes out,
you know, you're at seven to 9,000 feet in the tropics.
So it's really intense UV exposure and it dries things out instantly.
So it's really hard, hard climatic conditions for life. Wow.
That's wild. Yeah. And so these organisms, these creatures that live up there,
they're, they're closely resembling creatures that live in Africa.
And so that was part of what you were studying.
Yeah.
So we were with this biologist who was trying to do an elevational transect of,
of the river basin that we were in.
So basically starting from the rainforest where the frogs are pretty well-known
and then going up through the cloud forest,
which is kind of as you gain elevation to the actual wall and the species all
changes as you gain elevation, which is kind of normal.
And then the things on the summit of the taboos on the summit of the
stone island are completely different again.
And so he was basically doing research on how, how the different species,
you know, basically what the deal is.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs.
All for free Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.